[Music]
right
Resident Evil 5 or the Nintendo switch
highly anticipated you've been waiting a
long time if I can get over here and
every great all right
some cooperative action going on right
now classic series and the season
attendant continues support a lot of
great Resident Evil games
Capcom seems very supportive and we
already got zero part 1 and 4 and now
part
is a cooperative action
oh there we go stop doing it right there
you go
like they'd like that 30
[Music]
there
yeah we like running pigs a little
easier
[Music]
oh shoot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well
okay I'm
okay there we go there you go
oh shoot oh boy here we go
CEO and then zr
he was hired by
is holding okay yeah
come on come on shoot the other bullets
say it might be a bit
bullet count flow what okay
reload you failed me lb
there you go got down you got some ammo
there you go
[Music]
those drops
all right nice
I'm still alive so we're good
nice shot all right
hmm
preacher preacher
there you go
all right
all right
you all running it with bullets in your
hand and no
[Music]
crap
not straight on that AMOLED why
together
sure you get that reload in the night
like I'm left behind the NPR
probably got another way around
well maybe she can find something to
assist
to reload the
the trouble
shoot shoot don't you Cheever him
[Music]
other one other one other one that
looking good is looking smooth you
we were big
Resident Evil 5 cooperative action
[Music]
you
[Music]